Imagine if the internet took hold in China.
Imagine how freedom would spread
Unrestricted internet access is a source of strength.
That country has some of the toughest
internet restrictions in the world.
The government in China's tightening
up on internet restriction it says
because of the number of anonymous
postings that poke fun at the government.
So you think they're ultimately going to be on
the right side of history the Chinese government?
I am 100%. For sure because nobody can stop
this technology revolution.
It's 1987 in West Germany and a
university professor has just got an email.
It contains one short sentence.
He's just received the first email from China.
But it isn't until 1994 that the internet
becomes available to the public
under the presidency of Jiang Zemin.
Like many of his compatriots Jiang
is deeply influenced
by the work of Alvin Toffler
an American writer whose book Future Shock
predicts a super-industrial revolution
brought about by the moderation
and regulation of technology.
Computers combine facts to make new knowledge
at such high speed that we cannot absorb it.
But computers are expensive and
hardly anyone owns one
so the internet cafe is born.
It costs around 25 yuan or $3 for an hour.
In 1995 a former English teacher called Jack Ma
heads to the U.S. on business.
While he's there he does a
web search for the word beer
are no results about China.
He returns home and starts
an online yellow pages.
You don't make any money,
you've got extraordinary claims
and yet you make nothing.
That's the internet.
By 1999 the company Tencent releases OICQ
and Jack Ma creates Alibaba.
It's the Millennium and the unveiling
of the Golden Shield project
which includes a new surveillance system
made up of content-filtering firewalls.
The system becomes known around the world
as the Great Firewall of China.
It only takes a couple more years
for China to overtake the U.S.
and have the world's most Internet users
Fast forward and it's 2012.
Xi Jinping is elected general secretary
of the Communist Party
with a vision of "cyber sovereignty".
Protecting the country's internet
from foreign influence.
Notable restrictions include Winnie the Pooh
because of comparisons made to Xi Jingping
and the letter N.
It doesn't take long for controversial new laws
which "ensure cybersecurity" to appear.
These grant the government unprecedented
access to foreign companies
including their hardware and sensitive user data.
In 2018 Freedom House names China as the
worst country in the world for online freedom.
But China soon starts exporting
its to take on the Internet
to countries like Vietnam, Uganda
and Tanzania.